- I'm so happy to go home.
- [Evan] Why are you so happy?
- Because I miss home.
- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today is the day we're going home.
- [Evan] Day 8.
- Day 8, yae!
(kids groan)
I miss home.
I want to go home actually.
- Has it been a good week guys?
(kids say yes)
- That doesn't sound exciting.
(kids excitedly agree)
- We are rushing to the
airport behind schedule,
so here we go, excited.
It's been a good week.
We learned a lot of things.
We grew as human beings.
Learned some life lessons.
Right kids?
Right, yeah, tons of life
lessons, that was amazing.
And got to get to the
airport, got to get some gas,
get Nina coffee.
- [Nina] Hustle.
- Hustle and head home.
(light inspirational music)
Starbucks, hiring more
people, everywhere we go.
The Starbucks line is crazy.
Hire more people.
But I'm going to have
to stand in that line
because I love my wife,
she wants a coffee,
so I need to support her, hurray.
(inspirational music)
Look at that smile.
Someone is excited to have some coffee.
Where's mine?
- Oh.
- Oh, I'm filming.
You look like a giant
because I'm filming you up--
I got a caramel frappe.
- It's good.
We probably should go now.
- Oh yeah, that's good.
All right, it's time to get ready.
- We're here.
I'm so happy to go home.
- [Evan] Why are you so happy?
- Because I miss home.
- [Evan] You miss home?
How come?
- Because I miss home.
- [Evan] To eat healthy?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Being without three kids?
(Evan giggles)
- [Evan] Relaxing.
- Yes.
- [Evan] All right, well here we go.
- Hello, we're back.
- [Evan] How do you feel?
- In Toronto.
- [Evan] Happy?
- Umm-mmm.
- All right, we made it.
I'm a little bit nauseous.
I've been trying to watch
a movie on the phone,
and it being turbulent,
but it's good to be back.
Going to lose this T-shirt weather soon.
Step outside to, we saw a
little snow on the ground,
so we'll see what it's like,
but it feels good to be home.
Wife is happy to be home.
We're going to hop in the car.
We're going to hop in the car and go home.
What's the first thing you're going to do
when you get home?
- Shower.
- [Evan] Shower.
Yeah, I didn't want to
say anything, Nina, but--
- Yeah, whatever.
I can't even get close to
you because I can't stand it.
- Nina smells great.
I'm just causing problems.
(inspirational music)
Back in Toronto guys.
We made it.
- Home sweet home.
- We're all matching.
Look at the airplanes.
We made it.
- Home sweet home.
- Nina's very excited.
- Yeah.
- Nina's plants didn't
die while we were away.
Nina!
- [Nina] What?
The plants.
They look good.
- [Nina] They're all dead?
- [Evan] No, they look better than alive.
They look great.
- That's what I said, they'd be fine.
I water a lot before I went.
- Look at this one; it's great.
Almost ready to go outside.
I was really worried that
Nina's plants would die,
and it would make me very sad
because Nina would be very
said, but these look great.
So it's good to be back.
Shaking off my headache.
Wanted to share one final parenting tip
that we've picked up that helped.
The first one I talked
about in a previous video,
we did one present per
person, and they knew.
And actually they all knew they wanted
the Harry Potter wand before even going,
so they didn't even ask.
- [Nina] Yeah, they didn't ask.
- The whole time, right?
The whole time they didn't say I want this
and I want this and I want this.
That was really good.
I made that up, kind of four years ago,
and I think every year we just
made it more and more clear
earlier and earlier, and
that part was fantastic.
We didn't get bothered at all
about wanting different gifts
so that's amazing, like we got
to start preparing for that
for next year, one gift.
The other thing that we did that was new
that we made up on the spot
this year was time-outs.
So what I did was, so in our
family we don't do spanking.
We do time-outs, so you get
time-outs for misbehaving.
Any time they misbehaved or complained,
we gave them a minute time-out.
To get rid of a minute, they had to do
a good deed for somebody else.
It was a good, like we
started that like midway
through the vacation, I feel
like we're going to start
it sooner next year and
maybe ratchet up the points
a little faster, but I
think it worked out well.
They hated getting the time-outs,
and then they were
looking ways for trying--
- Trying to do good deeds.
- To do good deeds for people.
- Even before this time-out started.
- Yeah, so if they had a good
deed before they had minutes,
they got negative one minute.
I think that worked out well.
We got to try that next time.
Anyway, parenting tips from
Evan and Nina (laughs).
So that's it for us.
Hayden ...
Well, this is our last video.
- Yep.
- Hayden was a little
bit sad about hearing
this is the last video
we are going to make.
But thank you guys for joining
us on our Florida adventure.
What was your favorite part guys?
What was your favorite part?
- My favorite part.
Universal Studios.
- [Evan] Universal Studios, okay.
- [Nina] Universal Studios pretty good.
- [Hayden] I also liked the Simpsons ride.
- I got sick on that one.
- What do you call those, the
graphics, was really good,
the 3D graphics, the 4D.
- I liked being able to have humongous
Starbucks drinks every day.
I'm going to miss that.
Sometimes twice, going to miss that.
And spending time with my family, yeah!
- Yes!
- Well thank you guys for joining.
We believe in you.
We hope you to continue
to believe in yourself.
- And whatever your one word is.
- We'll see you soon.
- Much love guys.
- Much love, bye.